in the past there was what we call a
medical model of disability and this
model proposes that people with
disabilities are ill and need to be
fixed
more recently thinking has really
evolved toward a more social model of
disability and so the social model
emphasizes that many people with
disabilities are only disabled by the
way that society treats them so that
philosophy of the social model rather
than the medical model of disability is
something that the ability and enable
teams really embrace in our thinking
about technology you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using
[Applause]
with seven billion people on the planet
you might be surprised to learn that
approximately a billion of those people
experience some form of disability enter
principal researcher and research
manager dr. Mary Rangel Morris and the
ablity group at Microsoft Research
they're working to remove accessibility
barriers both to and through technology
empowering people with disabilities to
better perform their daily tasks today
dr. Morris gives us some fascinating
insights into the world of ability talks
about how technology is augmenting not
only sensory and motor abilities but
cognitive and social abilities as well
and shares how Microsoft through its AI
for accessibility initiative is
committed to extending the capabilities
and enhancing the quality of life for
every person on the planet that and much
more on this episode of the Microsoft
Research podcast
[Music]
marry Ringel Morris welcome to the
podcast
Thank You thanks I'm here so your
research falls under the general
umbrella of human-computer interaction
or HCI but you're a principal researcher
and a research manager of a relatively
new group in Microsoft Research tell us
what it is and what gets you up in the
morning so our new team is the ability
team and is a new group that's focused
on harnessing research at the forefront
of HCI human-computer interaction and
also AI in order to augment the
capabilities and extend the abilities of
people everywhere and in particular the
approximately 20% of the population that
has some form of disability so let's
drill in there a minute you have
referred to some pretty surprising
statistics give us a picture of the
ability spectrum from differing levels
categories in lengths even of
disabilities so the most recent US
census indicates that about one in five
Americans experience some form of
disability in their daily lives and
statistics from the World Health
Organization indicate that about 1
billion people worldwide are disabled in
some way and disability refers to a
spectrum of different condition that
includes sensory disabilities such as
challenges with vision and hearing that
includes motor disability that can
include speech and language disabilities
as well as cognitive disabilities such
as learning challenges autism attention
challenges etc and then of course in our
own research I think it's really
motivating to think about not only how
our research advances can specifically
assist those disability constituencies
but actually how advances in research
for people with disabilities tend to
benefit the usability of technology for
everyone because all of us at some point
in our lives experienced temporary or
situational disability
a temporary disability in the motor
space might be if someone breaks their
legs so they might be using crutches or
a wheelchair for a short period of time
and of course would then benefit from
technologies that assist people who have
more lifelong motor disabling conditions
but even situational impairments that
are much more fleeting affect all of us
if someone is pushing a grocery cart or
pushing a baby stroller just in that
moment they also in a sense have a motor
disability you know that's interesting
because I don't think most of us think
about disability in terms of that it
might be temporary and that all of us at
some point experience some kind of
disability so I think it's interesting
to broaden the vision of what that means
and how technology can help us there so
talk a bit about how your technologies
are aiming to help us so the ability
group has projects focusing in several
different areas in the cognitive space
we've been doing some work on how to
make search engines easier to use for
people with dyslexia so dyslexia is a
spectrum disorder it impacts about 15 to
20 percent of English language speakers
the incidence rate is different
depending on different languages but 15
to 20 percent of the population is quite
substantial yeah and people with
dyslexia experience a range of
challenges with spelling and reading
comprehension and of course search
engine use to find information online is
I would argue one of the most important
modern literacy skills today and so
we've been doing some basic studies to
understand first what are the challenges
that people with dyslexia experience at
different stages of web search so
choosing their query terms triaging the
information on the search engine results
page actually finding specific nuggets
of information within a webpage once
they've arrived at it and then thinking
about how we might change both the
ranking algorithms for search results
themselves as well as the interface for
presenting those results to make it
easier to use for that group
I think that that's also another really
interesting example of we're thinking
about a particular disabilities such as
dyslexia might yield a user interface
that impacts a much larger group of
people children who are still just
learning to read or people learning
English as a Second Language might also
benefit from many of these same
interventions that would benefit users
with dyslexia would you look at those as
applied to a broad audience I mean if
you're using algorithms that are on your
search engine everyone's going to
experience them right from the person
who's early reader to someone who's a
PhD well I think that's still a design
decision to be made is about whether you
would want these interface designs to be
applied generally across all users of
the service or whether it might be
another form of personalization so today
major search engines generally applied
different types of personalization right
so if you and I both were to search for
hamburger restaurant and I was searching
from Seattle according to the
geolocation of my browser and you were
searching from London we would actually
see different search results because the
results are actually being tailored to
something about us in this case our
location so you could imagine situations
where search results might be tailored
to someone's cognitive profile of course
that also raises potential privacy
concerns and we'll talk about that in a
bit
it's definitely something we're aware of
and so I think there are interesting
trade-offs in how you might personalize
or generalize these kinds of interface
designs
[Music]
there's another group within MSR under
the umbrella of human-computer
interaction called enable that you
collaborate with quite often why two
groups in this sort of the same zone and
how would you characterize the research
going on in each group absolutely so the
ability team and the enable team worked
together closely the ability groups
mission is in more foundational academic
work more fundamental scientific
research that then lays the basis for
advanced engineering efforts and
shipping more public-facing products by
the enable team so for example the
enable team shipped the hands-free
keyboard which was inspired by their
collaborations with Steve Gleason and
team Gleason which is a foundation for
people with ALS or Lou Gehrig's disease
and so the hands-free keyboard is an
improvement on I gaze interaction for
typing and then speech synthesis and so
the enable team led the engineering
efforts on that product but behind the
scenes they were collaborating with
myself and other members of the ability
team and we did more underlying academic
research that we shared broadly with the
community that influenced that product
we did research to understand what are
some of the limitations of eye trackers
for different users and different
lighting conditions and how might
interfaces adapt to those changes we
looked at new algorithms for mitigating
error in eye typing that can now let
users eye type more quickly because they
have to spend less time correcting
errors and we also did some fundamental
research about what end users want from
an AAC device in terms of how these
communication devices can let users more
authentically express their personality
so we were out on the ground doing
interviews with people with ALS to learn
about their current technology needs for
example how these devices currently
don't let people express humor sarcasm
artistic expression you know wanting to
be able to sing through your device so
we document the
NEADS and then we also propose
innovations in terms of how these
devices can express richer prosody and
other channels of feedback that might
support these needs in the future so
that's how the enable team in the
ability team worked together toward
shared goals so back to the the
accessibility technology and the
terminology when we think of
disabilities we most often think of
sensory and motor because they're the
most obvious ones and you refer to some
of the work you're doing with search
engines for cognitive challenges as well
is there anything else happening in the
cognitive range that is interesting in
this research so another area that our
team has been working on is technologies
for people on the autism spectrum
so Microsoft's is I think a leader in
beginning to think more actively about
this space particularly through our
inclusive hiring program so Microsoft is
now part of a consortium of companies
that are actively working to change
interview and hiring and retention
practices to help harness the
neuro-diverse talent in the software
engineering industry and so one thing
that the ability team is involved in in
addition to consulting with that program
to help design the inclusive technology
program but also to think about how our
software engineering tools and practices
as a tech company might need to be
altered and updated to better support
neurodiverse talent that's the first
time I've heard that phrase neurodiverse
is well I think there's some interesting
thinking in the accessibility space in
the area of disability studies that's
really changed over the past few years
so in the past there was what we call a
medical model of disability and this
model proposes that people with
disabilities are ill and need to be
fixed and that medical intervention is
the focus and more recently thinking in
that space has really evolved toward a
more social model of disability and so
the social model of disability
emphasizes that many people with
disability
our only disabled not by their own state
of being but by the way that society
treats them the onus is really on
society to adapt and be more inclusive
and the neurodiversity movement is one
manifestation of that so I think that
philosophy of the social model rather
than the medical model of disability is
something that the ability and enable
teams really embrace in our thinking
about technology again back to the when
we think of disability we often think of
sensory and motor and so on and we also
think of solutions that are meaningful
and important and so thinking of
something like social media and how
teens like to participate and be part of
the group and have their friends share
pictures and things like that tell me a
little about what you're doing for that
group of limited vision population in
the teen group yes so this past summer
we did some really interesting research
led by our intern Cindy Bennett who's a
student nearby at the University of
Washington to understand how teenagers
with vision impairment are using
photography and social media and we
included in that study teens with a
range of visual impairments so all of
the teens who participated were legally
blind but most of them would be
classified as having low vision but the
remainder of the group that we
interviewed relied to some degree on
their residual vision both of these
groups of teenagers whether they
completely lacked vision or had some
residual vision we're very interested in
using visual social media tools just as
any teen would be in order to
communicate and stay in touch with their
friends and participate in pop culture
so applications like Facebook Instagram
snapchat were all part of these teens
daily lives and observing the usability
challenges that this group experienced
was really interesting for thinking
about how we can redesign these kinds of
photography capture and editing
applications to make them more
accessible it's really important to all
teenagers to be able to take flattering
selfies
so this was particularly challenging for
people with low vision because in order
to take a selfie you need to hold the
camera at arm's length away from your
face that made it impossible for this
group to see on the screen whether they
were framed in a flattering way on the
camera or even more challenging if they
were using some apps that try to overlay
different lenses on you while it's
taking the selfie that couldn't tell
what those look like
or if they were aligned so thinking
about how you might have better audio
feedback in selfie cameras to give
people information to help them to the
left or right or you're completely in
the frame now or you're out of the frame
would be really helpful to that audience
another thing we saw the teens doing
that I was really surprised by was they
used filters in an interesting way what
we saw was that teenagers with low
vision in addition to using filters for
artistic purposes to kind of fit in with
their friends they were also using
filters to actually improve the visual
clarity of images for themselves right
so people would go through and choose a
filter because it best matched their
visual ability is to increase their own
perception of a photo and they would
even do things like download other
people's photos so that then they could
filter them in order to see them better
Wow and I think that suggests a lot of
again potential for technological
innovation in terms of actually
designing filters specifically for
different visual conditions that might
be optimized to improve visual clarity
for particular subsets of users rather
than only designing filters for
aesthetic purposes that's something that
your research team is looking at and
studying and it's on our list of things
to tackle going forward yeah so we have
I think an interesting pipeline in our
research so we do human-computer
interaction more broadly encompasses
several different research methods so it
includes research to understand users
needs so this is things like ethnography
and interviews and surveys and
observations to understand what users
really want and
need in technology so our team does a
great deal of that kind of work and then
the next layer is to build on that right
and now that we understand the needs in
technology and the potential for
innovation to actually build new
prototypes new algorithms new interfaces
that enable these kinds of expression
that we see a need for and that's also
again something that our team does so we
build prototypes and then actually
testing out these prototypes with users
to understand what works and what
doesn't and refine them and then of
course the next stage is actually
building on that knowledge to engineer
you know real systems that might be
shippable to an end user so it sounds
like you use the full spectrum of
research methodology from qualitative to
quantitative and then actual lab testing
of this stuff and then getting it out
into the world yeah so our team has
people with backgrounds in different
areas we have one researcher with a
background in psychology others like
myself with backgrounds in computer
science so we really have different
kinds of skills on the team
I think it's important to point out now
that your team conducts research at as
you call it the intersection of HCI and
AI and the AI part is super important
without it the research would look a lot
different I think so tell us how a AI is
changing the game for innovation in your
field and ability enabling and
human-computer interaction absolutely I
think there are a lot of AI advances
that are going to enable new experiences
for people with disabilities but I think
it's also vitally important that the
needs of that user population be
considered by people involved in the AI
research directly there's been an
explosion recently thanks to advances in
deep learning in the ability for
computer vision systems to label
photographs and that's wonderful and of
course to me an obvious application for
a system that can automatically label
photographs is to caption images for
people who are visually impaired because
when browsing the web right now a screen
reader can only describe an image if the
author of a webpage has supplied an alt
text for it description that's right at
about 50% of images on the web right now
on major websites lack alt text
completely so a blind user wouldn't
receive any description so one might
think well we'll use an these new AI
technologies to caption the images but
there are some challenges with that so
most of these technologies are not
developed right now with the scenario of
use by people who are visually impaired
so there's the assumption that if a
mistake is made in labeling the image
the cost of that mistake is relatively
low because a sighted user can see that
a particular image maybe doesn't match
the retrieval terms and just ignore that
mistake but for someone who's visually
impaired the cost can actually be quite
high and that I think is a more
fundamental problem in AI research that
I think our perspective from HCI and
working with end users can really inform
through collaboration right
let's talk about collaboration and
circle back to the inception of the
enable group and it began as a
partnership with team Gleason I'm not
sure everyone knows who Steve Gleason is
and what the collaboration started as
and how its advanced and grown sure so
the enable team which is led by rico mal
VAR who's the chief scientist of
microsoft research
they grew out of a partnership with team
Gleason as part of Microsoft's one week
hackathon and so Steve Gleason is a very
well known football player and he was
diagnosed at a relatively young age with
ALS which is also known as Lou Gehrig's
disease and as people with ALS progress
and they lose muscle control they need
to rely on other tools such as
wheelchairs for mobility and AAC devices
for communication and speech generation
and Steve was not satisfied with the
state of current technologies in that
area unfortunately there's no medical
cure right now for ALS and Steve is very
well known for a quote that I'll try to
reproduce accurately here so his
approximate quote is that while there is
no medical cure for ALS technology can
be the cure and so by that he means that
technology can really in this social
model of disability technology plays an
important role in removing barriers to
access and making people less disabled
in their daily interactions and so his
team has worked closely with Microsoft
on two particular projects which were
the initial projects of the enable team
one is allowing someone to use eye gaze
to drive their own wheelchair to have
more autonomy and then the other is in
improved interfaces for typing with eye
gaze so typically the way people with
ALS and other the serious motor
conditions communicate is through using
the eyes to type so you would stare with
your eyes at a particular letter on the
screen with an eye tracker for a set
amount of time until the system's
confident that you're looking at that
letter and then that letter would be
typed and you do that
one at a time and then you when you're
done typing something you would hit a
button that would speak that out in a
computer-generated voice and typically
people achieve typing rates that are
very slow about five to ten words a
minute whereas conversational English
speech is closer to 190 words a minute
so that is a huge impediment to
participation in daily life when you're
communicating that slowly yeah so just
letting people type letter-by-letter is
not gonna get you up to regular rates of
speech you need prediction and that's
where AI comes in again and so the
enable team has been working on better
user interfaces and better algorithms
behind the scenes and word prediction in
order to improve that kind of speech and
of course it's not just the word so
another thing we've been thinking about
is again how you let people express
themselves more quickly and more richly
and so like they say you know picture is
worth a thousand words
we've looked at adding a row of keys to
the communication devices that are
different emoji so representing the most
common human emotions anger surprise
sadness happiness and if you just add
one of these emoji to your sentence as a
punctuation so it's just one more key
press solo input from the user since
each input is such a great effort and we
use those to not only modify the
porosity of the output behind the scenes
but we insert clips of non-speech audio
so for example if you add a surprised
emoji to a sentence you might get
inserted and if you add that angry emoji
you might get like and zzzz communicate
such a great amount of emotion and
nuance for such a low effort a single
key press and that's been very well
received by users and some of our
research testing
[Music]
you talked about what you do with
universities and so on and I know you're
affiliated with the University of
Washington and you're involved in a
program called dub can you tell us what
that is
sure so dub is a little bit of a play on
words because of course the University
of Washington is abbreviated as you dub
but the dub research group it's spelled
D UB and it stands for design Hughes
build and so it's an interdisciplinary
consortium of faculty from several
different departments so computer
science the School of Information human
centered design and engineering Arts and
Design that are all interested in
creating technology that is more human
centric for end-users and myself and
several other researchers from Microsoft
Research are actively involved in
collaborations with dub so how did you
end up here give us a little bit about
your background and what brought you to
Microsoft research
sure so my background is that I studied
computer science as an undergraduate and
I went to Brown University which at the
time had a very traditional computer
science department so there was no HCI
and I learned about HCI
by browsing the web I found the website
of the Stanford interactive workspaces
project which was an early project
around ubiquitous computing so thinking
about how we can design spaces where
computing is embedded in the environment
and I remember that web page had a
picture of a room that at the time
looked very futuristic to me where there
were these large wall size displays and
a table with a display embedded in it
and it was really very futuristic
looking so I contacted the professor in
charge of that project at Stanford who's
Terry Winograd and to ask how I could
get involved in this kind of work and I
ended up doing some volunteer based
research projects with him and I
eventually went to graduate school in
the computer science department there
and that was kind of my route into
learning more about this field of HCI
and while I was at Stanford
I was fortunate to get an internship
with Microsoft research where I worked
with Eric Horvitz
and Susan Dumais on thinking about how
Desktop Search which was very new at the
time how you could allow people to use
context that they might remember to
assist in search so instead of only
searching for something by the file name
you could specify other things that you
might remember like I remember it was
that PowerPoint document that I wrote
the day after the presidential election
or oh it was that email someone sent me
right after my son's birthday party and
that you could use these anchors that
were more meaningful and memorable to
people that file names as a way in to
search for information and so that was a
really exciting project that kind of
expanded my knowledge and got me into
thinking about information retrieval but
I also learned about the culture of
Microsoft Research and then I was
excited to come and work here when I
graduated given the insights that you
get from the work you're doing which is
both powerfully beneficial for good but
could also have some downsides is there
anything that sort of keeps you up at
night I think one is in thinking about
AI systems that are more inspectable and
understandable not only inspectable by
AI researchers which is in and of itself
still a challenge but inspectable by end
users so that they can really understand
when to place their trust in a system
and what a system is doing I think there
are challenges in developing AI systems
that balance augmenting users
capabilities with the privacy needs of
the users themselves and people in the
surrounding environment so let's say one
might imagine hypothetically that
someone who's visually impaired might
benefit from having an outward facing
smart camera that's a wearable that
could sense things in the environment
using computer vision and describe that
to someone so that could potentially
have a great benefit to the end-user but
might have a privacy cost too
in the surrounding environment who may
not be actively consenting to being
captured and I think thinking carefully
about those kinds of ethical challenges
is actually a really important part of
AI research and I know Microsoft has now
formed a group called ether AE th ER
which is thinking specifically about AI
and ethics so the a is for AI the e is
for ethics and I think that's one of the
areas that will be really interesting to
tackle Microsoft just announced a new
initiative at the annual build
conference that's pretty exciting tell
us what it is who it will impact and
what it tells us about Microsoft's
broader mission for technology in the
21st century yes so you're referring to
the AI for accessibility initiative so
this is an exciting new program that is
designed to help support grassroots
innovation in the accessibility space so
Microsoft is really interested in
encouraging students entrepreneurs etc
it's you think about how you can use
Microsoft technologies to enable
important scenarios for people with
disabilities so for example how can we
use these technologies to allow people
to be more productive in their work life
or participate more fully in social life
outside of work
yeah and so the AI for accessibility
initiative offers funding opportunities
that people can apply so you describe
how your project or app would fit into
this vision and how Microsoft can help
support your success in this space
perhaps by donating compute time on our
azor servers or allowing free api calls
to our cognitive services api's which
offer shortcuts to some of our advances
in AI technology like libraries for
computer vision and for natural language
processing so we're really excited about
this initiative we're excited to see
what kinds of great project proposals
and applications come in
and I think it accentuates Microsoft's
commitment to its mission statement of
empowering all users in their lives and
I think empowering all users really
refers to all users including the 1
billion people worldwide with
disabilities and so it's great to see
that being emphasized in this new
initiative
Mary Engle Morris I so enjoyed our
conversation today my eyes were open
shall we say thank you for coming in and
sharing the work that you're doing and
the passion behind it great thank you
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Barry Ramo
Morris and how a eye is helping people
with disabilities all over the world
visit microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]